I was only 17
when I first applied to do ROTC.
I didn't come
from a military family,
so it wasn't really something
we expected.
But after that, ended up
sticking with it.
Now I'm here.
My name is Brandon Colas.
I'm an Army lieutenant colonel.
I've been in the service
for 17 years now
and I’m a foreign area officer.
I’m here at Yale. It's my first
year in the
political science PhD program.
Yale has a long history
of veterans service
being part of this community
of scholars,
at least for me, there's
been something satisfying in
whether you served a full career
or just for a few years,
you joined something
that was a lot
bigger than yourself
and made a commitment.
And there's something
honorable and special in that,
and it gives me great
pride to be a
part of that along with you.